l'appareil faut encore le maître a servi
pour federico et pascal c'est le jour du
grand départ thap l'une des prix dans
quelques heures ils vont s'envoler pour
l'inde un voyage un peu spécial qu'il
prépare depuis longtemps vous avez prévu
beaucoup de choses hein pour le voyage
maintenant en fait c'est quoi ces deux
sacs à couches il est recueilli 7,3 la
nuit feront très 8,9 degrés mais donc le
sac de couchage ont quand même pas mal
et puis c'est la trousse avec tous les
médicaments
déroule à lacombe avaient leur bail au
campement pendant cinq six ans on
restera là bas on sera sous la tente pas
de chauffage reste quand même pas
d'endroit pour caser nos affaires donc
ce serait assez route
ils vont assister au plus grand
pèlerinage religieux indiens
la combat mais là je fais un parallèle
entre ça et woodstock ce que j'ai à vous
de stock mais woodstock à côté ressemble
à une fête de village ce qui les attend
c'est une tout autre ambiance
la kumbhamelâ le pèlerinage le plus
important de l'hindouisme la première
religion indienne
[Musique]
c'est le plus grand rassemblement humain
au monde 70 millions de personnes
l'équivalent de toute la population
française qui vient se baigner dans le
gange pour se purifier de ses péchés
un hindou se doit d'y aller au moins une
fois dans sa vie mais c'est aussi un
campement géant une ville éphémères qui
s'installent pendant deux mois à 600 km
de la capitale new delhi à allahabad au
confluent du gange et de deux autres
fleuves considérée comme sacrée le
pèlerinage est devenu un événement
planétaire une expérience sans précédent
pour les deux amis
[Musique]
comme il est
pascal et federico en 34 ans pascal
travaille pour l'office public des
demandeurs d'asile federico et
réalisateur de publicités ils sont amis
depuis 20 ans ils ont pris deux mois de
congé pour venir en inde le pèlerinage a
motivé leur voyage pas pour la
spiritualité plus tôt pour les
sensations fortes du raid parce que la
découverte d'une planète
un autre univers
des choses qu'on n'a pas l'habitude de
la voir si nous comme ça en europe et ça
fait longtemps qu'on se dise vrai ce
faire un voyage à deux en inde et la
possibilité d'un pauvre mais là et des
opportunités quoi après six heures de
train les voici enfin arrivé à allahabad
pascal est déjà venu en inde mais pour
federico c'est une première une plongée
immédiate dans la foule indienne
direction les rives du gange le fleuve
sacré des hindous sur les berges les
deux amis croiser les premiers pèlerins
voulu se baigner
quoi excellent
un moment de ferveur
mais aussi de joie partagée en famille
[Rires]
c'est la jonction du gange dollars
yamuna et du saraswati les trois
rivières se rejoignent ici et c'est pour
ça que c'est le lieu sacré où nous
venons nous baigner
mais la meilleure date pour se baigner
et dans deux jours quand l'alignement
des planètes sera parfait selon les
astrologues pour purifier les péchés en
attendant le grand bain federico et
pascal vont prendre un peu de repos la
plupart des pèlerins dorment sous la
tente les plus pauvres à la belle étoile
ceux qui ont plus de moyens loue des
chambres dans des baraquements comme
celui ci monte le temps du pèlerinage
pascal a réservé deux places par
internet des cabanes en tôle au confort
plutôt de dimanche air
et voilà les dortoirs voilà notre dos
poire
mercredi
[__] c'est à dire ouais ça c'est le
matelas
l'a énoncé par la douche juste pour ça
c'est comme ça les a vérifiés
il va falloir se laver au sou et à l'eau
froide
50 euros pour dormir à 10 dans un
dortoir pas vraiment bon marché
couvert après le jour c'est nickel c'est
clair que ça si tu acceptes tu
sais ce que c'est
pour une chambre avec eau chaude les
prix s'envolent jusqu'à 300 euros
mais après des heures de marche parce
qu'elle est federico ne font pas les
difficiles
mais leur nuit va être beaucoup plus
courte que prévue
une heure du matin l'orage s'abat sur la
combat mais là un vrai déluge on a cru
que ça allait nous tomber sur la bière
le toit de tôle du dortoir n'a pas
résisté le réveil en pleine nuit sous
une trombe d'eau est un peu brutal
on fait bloc là c'est laid
le
à ces extrêmes quand même huawei pour
tous et des chambres à 50 euros la nuit
la faire
béchir nafie
les autres chambres à 300 euros la nuit
n'ont pas été épargnés cette touriste
italienne découvre les dégâts sur son
passeport et le responsable de l'hôtel
doit faire face à la colère des clients
on veut être remboursés
on ne s'y attendait pas vous n'étiez pas
préparé à ça
si on était préparés mais non il a plus
seulement 10 minutes vous n'étiez pas à
préparer
moi je pense surtout à ceux qui sont là
au bord du gange en des temps de fortune
qui prennent la bouée qui sont toujours
pas imaginer quelle est ta vie doivent
être viables
surtout ça
pascal et federico vont finir leur nuit
dans une autre chambre les pieds dans
l'eau mais au moins les lys on sait qu
il n'y a plus qu'à espérer qu'il le
reste
le lendemain le soleil est revenu sur la
combat mais là nous sommes à la veille
du grand bain le jour le plus important
du pèlerinage 30 millions de personnes
vont affluer en 24 heures un record
historique
malgré les péripéties de la nuit
federico et pascal sont dans l'ambiance
c'est l'appel à la rude naga bave
l'ena gabas sont des sages qui ont voué
leur vie aux dieux leur particularité
ils vivent nus le corps couvert de
cendres ils sont vénérés par les hindous
et considérés comme des saints leurs
bénédictions et précieuse
[Musique]
baba quel âge avez-vous
22 ans à un jeune baba
on va faire une offrande obama
où que nous soyons nous les naga baba
les fidèles viennent nous voir nous
sommes des icônes des représentations
des dieux et plus les fidèles viennent
nous voir plus nous ressentons de la
joie
pour montrer leur détachement vis-à-vis
de la sexualité lena gabas malmène
publiquement leur pénis jusqu'à y
planter un billet de banque
ou seul ont roulé autour d'un sabre pour
porter un des leurs
mais ce sont aussi des guerriers gare à
ceux qui les regarde de trop près
[Musique]
mieux vaut ne pas trop les provoquer
on ne va voir plus loin depuis
dans le camp voisin federico et pascal
vont encore faire de drôles de
rencontres
ici les hommes sont tous vêtus en orange
et semble très occupé à fumer une
étrange qui panthères le chi l'homme
pour eux donc ses 17 feed de de
[Musique]
quelques notations chez tous ces rituels
donc ça pas du tout la même connotation
quand l'europe c'est dans un but
d'élévation de spiritueux à l'extérieur
comme en france l'usagé de drogues est
illégal en inde est puni de prison mais
il est toléré pour ces hommes très pieux
et très respectée
[Musique]
nous on est des ça d'où on vient de
toute l'inde
nous sommes totalement dévoué au dieu et
à la méditation
vous vous n'êtes pas pur vous n'avez pas
pris de bain vous avez des bactéries ou
un bep bac il ya
le ca do est une sorte d'ermite qui
renonce aux biens matériels et consacre
sa vie à la prière
mais celui ci a aussi le sens de
l'hospitalité
c'est votre tante
insigne honneur
les deux amis sont invités à boire un
chat le traditionnel thé indien
impossible du coup d'échapper aux autres
spécialités locales comme ces boulettes
au contenu un peu mystérieux
pascal ne le sait pas mais dans ce
gâteau il y a aussi un peu d'eux oui par
cracher c'est trop tard
la moitié c'est compliqué de refuser
quand même quoi il paraît que ça se fait
pas normalement donc on essaye de faire
semblant va j'essaie de faire semblant
pascal lui a pas pu faire autrement que
de manger un morceau mais j'ai testé ça
va un rite de bienvenue qui fait un peu
tourner la tête
à la tombée du jour le pèlerinage prend
des allures de las vegas ça scintille et
papillotes
away
de nombreux guides spirituels issus des
différents courants hindouiste trouve là
une occasion unique de recruter de
nouveaux adeptes on les appelle les
gourous et certains sont prêts à tout
pour séduire les fidèles et se faire
remarquer
jusqu'à prendre des allures de rockstar
[Musique]
c'est la nuit la plus folle et la plus
longue de la combat mais là le grand
bain le plus attendu du pèlerinage doit
avoir lieu à l'aube comme des millions
d'indiens pascal et federico vont devoir
marcher toute la nuit pour arriver aux
branches
cette marée humaine
ça c'est pas en voyage quand on parle
par expérience
heures à 3 heures du matin 30 millions
de personnes tentent de se frayer un
passage jusqu'au fleuve
et la police a de plus en plus de mal à
contenir la foule
[Applaudissements]
faut pas se poser de questions
enfin lors du grand bain arrive
des milliers de naga babass se ruent
vers le gange
ils sont toujours les premiers à se
baigner
pour les hindous ses hommes sains
purifie encore plus l'eau du gange et
les pèlerins se pressent pour aller à
l'eau juste après eux
mais ils n'auront droit qu'à quelques
minutes dans l'eau la zone de baignade
est réduite à 3 m car beaucoup d'indiens
ne savent pas nager alors il faut faire
vite à la dépêche toi laisse la place
aux autres
au dessus de la mêlée les haut parleurs
crachent leur dit si belle et les noms
de tous ceux qui se sont perdus dans la
foule
sur ces bouts de papier ils inscrivent
leur nom pour que les policiers lancent
un appel au micro
j'ai perdu mon mari
vous avez fait une annonce
je sais ni lire ni écrire comment je
peux faire
se perdre ici est un vrai drame la
plupart sont des paysans venus de
lointaines campagne sans un sou en poche
pour se payer un autre billet de train
ce jour là vingt mille personnes seront
séparés de leurs proches noyés dans la
foule pendant plusieurs heures
pascal et federico eux ne se sont pas
perdus ils tentent d'échapper à la cohue
par la voie d eau
au beau milieu du gange ils découvrent
une oasis de sérénité les baigneurs ont
pied les familles indiennes peuvent se
purifier loin des rives surpeuplé
temps c'est réaliste on dirait qu'on est
en plein milieu de la mer qu'ils ont
tous brillé partout
la tentation cette fois est trop forte
le grand bain c'est leur tour c'est
parti on y va on se lance pour voiler
fable irrésistible
vous venez d'où de delhi
enchanté on est venu prendre un bain
sacré dans le manche
après la tension et la cohue c'est enfin
le moment pour les deux amis de se
détendre
et de faire le plongeon sacré m trois
fois la tête dans le gange
[Rires]
[Musique]
pascal et federico reviendront peut-être
pour la prochaine combat mais là en 2025
en attendant ils vont poursuivre leur
voyage en inde mais selon la croyance
hindoue ils sont désormais sous la
protection des dieux pour les 88
prochaine génération